so electron how many people have heard
electron besides good how many people
have used electron all right awesome
hopefully I won't put you to sleep the
rest of you hopefully you'll enjoy the
journey so why am I here
I have a slight mental defect I actually
like standing up here and talking to
people secretly wanting to be a teacher
then I saw a teacher pay you X software
pay okay we know her career path I
recently wrote a co-authored a book for
a press with my good friend Leif Wells
on electron from beginner to pro
actually I have a copy here we'll figure
out a raffle as well is an interesting
book we took a different approach and
writing it you actually really don't
build an app in there cuz I know how
many people have like got in the
technical books and like how many people
have done in to do rap you know there's
real value in to do app I'm not going to
throw that away
but there's an issue with electron that
you'll understand as we go through of
why we didn't have you build an app in
there so I'm gonna teach with that
thoughts I'm still an Adobe community
professional mostly working in PhoneGap
Cordova as well as experiences i I am a
actually UX lead for a home automation
and security company down in Carlsbad so
driving north wasn't so bad it wasn't
coming from downtown San Diego I have a
cup of courses of Lynda and I've also
written a book on the ionic framework
for Riley so what is electron well Wayne
was actually released back in 2013 so
we're talking his five year old system
where it's just about to hit the 2.0
release so it's been chugging along it
was actually written by a Jing Chou
he actually worked on another project
called in wjs node webpage is and then
actually moved over and then basically
it was the foundation for the atom
editor so how many people use atom okay
how many people you it's vyas code okay
alright there's a reason those are all
electrons so the idea behind electron
is it's actually a blending of
technologies it's a blend of nodejs it's
a blend of chromium which is basically
the actual engine inside of chrome the
browser so chrome is the browser of all
the things like bookmarks all that the
actual web rendering engine is chromium
these two things together are what sort
of make electron natural I was going to
do the anything about Duncan a lot of
the apps on your computer are probably
built with electron
I almost when I do ion talk to something
saying same things like well have the
apps on your phone or probably actually
written in PhoneGap you don't know this
lot of the apps probably on your
computer are also now written in
electron so obviously atom github was
drinking their own champagne and built
the atom editor that was the foundation
of their BS code my favorite editor who
would have thought hey I'm I'm a little
old I guess I'm grading guess you grade
like would say yes I like a Microsoft
product it's hard to say but it isn't
you know though actually they're both
great editors you mentioned slack
there's another electron based app did
have desktop another one postman if
you're not familiar with that which is a
great API remote inspector the WordPress
desktop app and the list goes on though
you can actually pull up that URL and
just keep scrolling all the apps you've
never heard of but it's a great solution
because it allows the development
community to again have that one
language that one set of tools and now
come to the desktop it's very similar to
almost like the sales pitch and that I
give about PhoneGap and Cordova same
idea one code base multiple platforms so
what is electron bring to the table what
does it give us as a desktop app
building solution automatic updates so
in this age of agile development and
always adding new features because there
are no bugs just new features you know
we have a way to you know push updates
to our users native menus so if you've
been doing some web app development
there are hard walls fine I have this
beautiful web app but I have the chrome
menu bar the Firefox maybe why I have to
somehow fake some sort of interior menu
bar that's clunky kludgy doesn't fully
work right now I'm trying to hack in and
override keyboard shortcuts to try to
make no we can get that notifications
things we had that sort of an engine so
I'd say hey you know we all use slack
slack notifications hey you just got a
new you know DM or whatever crash
reporting ok yeah there might be bugs
you might want to know about them
profiling windows installers Mac
installers on and on so it actually
brings the table a lot what you would
need in your utility built to make a
desktop app because most people don't
write desktop apps they're a rare breed
and say even like trying to find someone
to write a native desktop app it's
harder to find this is someone who like
oh can you find a swift developer and I
find a you know a a Java developer to do
something for Android that's not people
will harder beauty is you can ship to
all three platforms so I can write
roughly with one code base ship for the
Mac ship for Windows and even ship for
those penguin love them people out there
in the world as well so and this has a
lot of value especially you start
thinking about the enterprise world
where if you I used to work at Qualcomm
you step behind the firewall into the
land of IT and all sudden you know here
are hundreds of these web apps and
applications to make the backend world
oh wait I can start doing some stuff
that I can't do and really provide some
value so how does this all work
talked about no talk about chromium real
fast electron is really built upon to
silence it's built upon this main
process silo and it's built upon a
render or silo these two processes run
simultaneously and this is probably the
you
sort of mental shift going from a web
app development world into an electron
development world because these two
friends have a way to talk to each other
but you have to explicitly tell them -
the main process that's really where
you're going to mostly interact with
that node component of electron that's
where you're gonna pull in a lot of your
node modules this is what's going to
allow you all the cool desktop stuff
that you can't do in a browser when you
start to do some browsers are getting
better but if I want to talk to the file
system right - the files launched other
applications put up your native
dialogues things like that that's gonna
live over in this main process just
mostly inode list of where I think it
was that's where my nodes stuff lives
the renderer process this is that UI
layer this is all living in that
chromium side of the world
this is when I paint on the screen to
show my users something and those are
the two parts now the interesting thing
is you actually don't have to have this
part you don't have to have a renderer
you have something it's just a main
process so if you've got some little
batch job or something you can actually
make a headless faceless electron app
and do something with it so let's face
it we're software developers were lazy
if we can find a way to automate a
process we'll do it and you can start
doing doing things like that you know
making your life easier that's what it's
all about that UI layer I mentioned it
really briefly it doesn't have one this
is actually sort of the hard part of
electron that is a blank web canvas just
like your web apps are you have to make
some informed decision about some
framework somewhere to come up and
develop a UI later
just like Cordova Cordova is a blank
slate it doesn't care if you're using
framework seven ionic onsen your own
same thing over here
so depending on what the background you
have you can pick your technology to
render that UI layer so you know the
angular people the world a little boring
the angular world we can use angular if
you're a react fan boom you want to play
around use joy yes great backbone Ember
heck you know if you're old-school you
want to go jQuery UI you can do that
roll your own heck you can even use
ionic which I've done it's the real
challenge that's why we actually didn't
have you build an app in our book
because if I wrote a sample app to do an
angular guess who I just piss off the
reactor view people and if I did react
people I'm gonna piss the angular people
off so we actually just kept rather just
playing simple JavaScript and really
didn't go too deep because it's like all
right how many times do I want to write
that to-do app and you know try to come
up with some artificial so that's the
one big challenge with electron is that
UI layer what are you gonna pick because
what you do an electron isn't
necessarily that hard said I mean you
some dialogues and things like that it's
still the hard engine as the business
logic the UI side that's where the sort
of the challenge of an electron
development comes in so installing it
heck
everything's NPM boom drop it real
simple now they have a little quick
little gig starting this is that just
man actually will hop out and do a
little more demos in am it basically
clone their starter has a few things
change the directory reset you get flags
npm start boom you got your initial
electron app and it looks really sexy
yeah you know hello world there's some
interesting stuff that actually goes on
if you actually will walk through the
gets here old do it here so you
literally have six files six files
basically and then the node modules
start and create my desktop application
even less because you know who cares
buffle
licensed we always forget which one do
we want you know MIT whatever we have an
index.html couple JSON files and a
package JSON that's the start now in
reality you're probably gonna start you
know having directories and making
things a little nicer you know you're
probably gonna start putting
everything's I have an app folder you're
gonna have a build folder or a disk
folder things of that nature to get it
more so the main j/s so the main J's
file this is what electron is going to
point to well by default the
package.json points the main yes if you
want to change convention you camp but
just main J yes this initial javascript
file is what electrons are going to boot
up from and the nice thing is since
we're living on top of some modern stuff
we can actually start to write in a
little more modern fashion now we're
gonna be writing the main Jass in j/s
the renderer side you know if you want
to live over in the land of type script
or something else you can do that over
here you're basically running yes thanks
basically pull an electron we define a
browser window do things like path URL
eventually we're gonna call and create a
window
Wednesday hey make me a new window when
at this height this wide tell it what to
load up in there not a lot to it to get
started
now remember it's chromium so all those
skills you have like that chrome dev
tools we have it built in it's the Air
Force so everything that you kind of
have gotten used to working with as part
of that muscle memory of figuring out
starts to be there now unfortunately
because you're moving out of the browser
into a desktop app some of the
responsibilities start to move back onto
you like cleaning up after yourself when
Windows clothes and listening to all
these other events so some of the things
you've never had to worry about before
now become your responsibility like
going from being a teenager to like a
young adult like what do you mean I
gotta pay rent and do laundry my twins
are 17 we're in that phase so we have a
unready event so all of us who have
lived in the land of you know
document.ready or cordoba developers
device ready we got ours yeah because
this is still gonna take you know a few
moments to boot up and things and splash
screens and you got to deal with that
world the HTML side is pretty
straightforward it's just HTML so the
next thing is even though we're just
barely getting to 200 with electron
there's lots of little minor updates
they actually keep the chromium engine
really really really really really fresh
like within a day or two and they
basically you got a new it so whatever
is getting poured into the latest
version of chromium in terms of support
for new features and the evolution you
know html5 1.2 etcetera etc all the new
JavaScript is available to you and the
nice thing is you're walking that inside
of your electron app so you know what
you're going to get you're not beholden
to mismatches so you could actually make
the electron even if say your enterprise
company says thou shalt use only ie or
something you know and there's that as
bad as it was but you know you may be
trapped in a legacy system or heaven
forbid you know they're still running
Windows 7 or something I 11 with
Tron basically you have a captive
browser so you can use the new stuff
that you want to use and makes life a
whole lot easier that's a nice thing
there but you know we have our script
engine here so we have another script
engine also so we can figure out
processes so this is what actually wrote
that you hey what version of Chrome I'm
running probably really
my version electron my version of node
over there real exciting and then I'm
basically pulling this where in your JS
file so Windows so not the operating
system but the actual application window
we actually have a whole lot of
parameters so out of the box that first
one just had width and height we
actually have a whole bunch of
attributes we can set up on our window
and we're not restricted to one window
I'll show an example so second windows
how to make a fake splash screen sort of
thing show you that so we can say
whether it's window to be shown or not
our background color we can restrict the
width and the height to the things so
you know we can only make it so small
because as a UI person there's a point
where like yeah I know you can shrink
down the window but I can't refactor the
UI this app to that point I need a
minimum of this you know it's a dated
table I can't make any smaller I can
even make it not movable so if I
actually was making some sort of you
know dashboard II think I could you know
walk all these things in positions and
not have anyone like muck them up I can
have it always be on top I can change
the title lots of capabilities I can
actually make frameless windows so if I
don't want the window chrome I don't
have to have the window chrome I can
also make my window transparent if I
want it to that was a lot of fun that
was an interesting one I don't know if
anyone has used this and no one's
written in but I've seen some web
measurement apps that you can fire up
and it will act as overlays on top of
the browser you're trying
take screen measurements and that sort
of thing that's what you could use this
potentially for yeah so here's a
transparent one so yeah there's a
attribute transparent true if I plan to
be transparent I'd see this stuff
through this the content in the HTML is
there but the window itself is
transparent you can do interesting
things mention this earlier menus this
is obviously one of the big
differentiators between the browser
world in the desktop world and when you
launch any sort of application you have
a menu bar that has all the things that
you want to do with it not what chrome
wants to do what Firefox wants to do we
have that capability and this is
actually what usually winds up would be
the bigger blocks of code in my electron
apps because you have to define all
those menu items and the structure and
it becomes something about this long ten
times longer for a fully fledged menu so
basically we tell it to build from a
template we set the application menu and
away we go
what does that template look like well
is basically a big long nested message
JSON file so we give label and the first
label that's what scrolling across the
top of the menu bar and then the sub
menus are the things underneath and you
can have sub menus in there ad infinitum
ahead of time now you can update this on
the fly you can change what things are
enabled so everything you think you need
to do with the menu you can do it's not
a hack now what's nice is they have both
accelerators and roles because when
you're stepping into the land of the
desktop world there are lots of
conventions you know cut copy paste
etcetera etc you don't need to rewrite
those they understand that those are
sort of core functionality and that's
where that role comes that so they sort
of automatically handle that for you
by adding that role they know what you
want to do you can't override it so if
you put that in your you basically have
a contract with electron that this is
how it's going to work so you have
something custom you're gonna have to
call your own function but we can also
define our accelerators those are the
keyboard shortcuts and you'll see you
that first one you know command or
control hey I can deliver to both
platforms I'll smack people it's you
know commands see the windows folks this
control see it handles both of those
worlds working it knows what OS it's
running on and will adapt to that so
here's an example screenshot of a a menu
being instantiated so there are you know
my modifier is up there here's the
submenu I have a checkmark under there
all that is within my electron control
so as I'm moving things in and around I
can do all that contention ones how many
people try to do a contextual menu in
their web app letter - yeah it was fun
wasn't it yeah just it was probably the
most happiest things you'd ever attempt
and yeah and you still probably got your
tickets from QA saying it didn't work
yeah yeah yeah so we get them as well so
this is just basically another variation
of the menu element so we can have OS
proper contextual menus inter
application and we can either set them
globally or on an item-by-item basis so
depending on when your app needs to do
so again to the end user they have this
is all the right set of tools they have
no idea what's this threaten it so here
I have a contextual menu building it
from a template
usually the contextual menus are a
little simple over that all the nesting
in the menus custom functions right in
here and then I just set it right here
to a window event listener so this one
would just
anywhere I click inside my application
this will show up but you know I want it
on a specific button in your Pacific
element you know I just knew where I
attached that event listener to see you
know we get nice things you know fat
arrow functions so all the cool things
you're learning like here at fuse you
know all great this is the magic between
the two worlds so I was talking about
those two silos The Avett main silo you
got there in your silo they don't talk
to one another kind like my twins I
employ girl twins they talk usually
yelling it was emptying the dishwasher I
PC so like us like me and my wife when
parents we're communicating between
these two the IPC this is the channel
between these two processes because
basically these are kind of sort of
segregating there is a way to actually
call functions within each other you can
but what I have found and talking with
other developers it tends to get little
Mestre messy that way they really do
like to sort of keep UI stuff over here
really separation concerns and stuff
that's really sort of OSE over on the
main but a great example of where that
baton handoff would be was I click on a
button over here then I want to open
like a save dialog same dialogs over in
the other side of the world so I need to
tell it ain't go from the dialog and
then the dialog needs to tell same
eye-to-eye
oh here's your file path and oh okay I'm
done now do this or whatever
it's the IPC that allows us to talk back
and forth IPC actually comes in two
flavors it comes in a synchronous
portion version as well as an
asynchronous version so this is the sync
version so pull it in and you know
they're really cryptically named IPC
renderer IPC main usually keep it
straight
plus
two in the morning and your chapters do
basically here we were attaching it to a
button to have on my UI click and
basically send synchronous this message
with that and over here so this part
right here that's sort of the name of my
token I'm sending over and over in the
renderer it says hey if I get an IPC
message with this basically as the
message header then pull these argit's
and do this and then I can basically
send back the return value now it's all
locked up synchronous we may want
something a synchronous very type is
similar hey we're going to send over and
then same idea so depending how your UI
and your interaction because sometimes
you may want to lock something up until
it's done sometimes you may not or may
run so a great place where this gets
used is actually pulling up and kicking
off dialogues so you know we have some
files we're starting to get more and
more file access with our browser but
you know the native alert dialog in a
web browser is on a scale of one to ten
I'm glad about a one I mean it's you
know it's funny it's actually like one
of the first things you actually show
name one's done mini Cordova work same
thing you pull up but you make a phone
gap app you have a JavaScript alert and
this is your index.html a little arm
like oh well that's not nice so the
first thing you do is like you're gonna
give me a dialog same thing here
how do you give me a dialog well we got
them we actually have several variations
of them so we have a file open and a
file save we have a message box which is
really sort of your alert info box we
all said this special alert box
sometimes the naming in github kind of I
love to hit that wayback machine because
Kony's box
I don't fully get I'd love to like how
that one who lost the bet you know an
air box is something you can fire off
very very very very fast in the start of
your application if something went
horribly horribly wrong but but the cool
ones are like the file open so this
basically is where that IPC stuff starts
to come into play again
so here we have a dialogue we're gonna
say hey go open the director dialogue
boom go do this and then we're gonna get
a nice-looking file dialogue we have a
lot of opportunities with the open so we
can actually filter on the file the
directory multiselection
if I want to be need to be able to
create a directory so all these
capabilities you would want in a desktop
application are there I can even you
know show the hidden files it's like up
you know you're writing a text editor oh
yeah that dot did ignore that you
actually need to go at it I can show
that you because hidden and actually
there's some nice thing on windows we
can actually prompt the create so here's
a little more here's a save you know
hide extension a a lot of the things are
all there for us so message boxes these
are really dialog boxes in my world very
similar except now we start to find your
buttons whose default what cancel is
because remember is you start moving in
the desktop world yeah you know do you
think about keyboard interaction
accessibility those sorts of things so
when I hit you know escape to cancel who
am I talking to what am i working with
message in detail there are four
variations so an info an error a
question and a none on the Mac side
they're all the same
there really there is no visual
difference between them windows actually
does something with those variations so
the
pending on my type you know I can get
different icons in there and had a
little bit of elements of how they
layout now you were not bound to the
default icons you can actually have your
own custom icon your custom image so
basically we have a module in there
called native image tell it where our
little icon is and then we can just pass
that in as an icon so you know your
visual designers crafted a beautiful
application icon and then you can pull
out the warning triangle on the corner
and make it look nice and pretty or
something else you know I was talking
earlier that that UI layer was all about
chromium we have all of these web
content events that we can listen to and
hook into and start to do something with
so depending on what your application
needs to do you know do the cursor
change should I do something
if the dev tools were open do something
they fill the load did I you know media
started playing plug-in crashed uh you
can actually run flash inside there just
just so you know if you actually need it
to and you will navigate all these
things these are all the pins and things
you can start to listen into if your
application needs to work with them
alright let's talk about some of the sad
parts of the world debugging because I
know everyone in this room you know
writes flawless code but your co-workers
may not you know how do you handle that
well the renderer process actually we
have chromium's dev tools right there
for us so we have our console log we can
go in look at the HTML why is the CSS
misbehaving what's going on I can go at
it from there
the main process actually is a little
harder because this is a little bit
inside the land of node we actually can
implement and use vs code
code tools it's two buggies to eat in
there and if you are a no person you're
familiar with note inspector you pull
that in and start playing in over on
that end of the world because those two
silos are are truly silos you know you
may be putting console logs over there
but you're not going to see them in the
console log that you would see over on
the renderer side so there is another
extension actually a dev tools extension
called Deb Tron it has some interesting
stuff I used a little bit it didn't
knock my socks off it's kind of like
okay it's there but it the only thing I
would say is it does help a little bit
about some of the IPC communication is
stuff going back and forth that's really
at one part of the world what you're
living in it's two worlds same time all
right how many people test write unit
tests in more hands more hands fix that
I'm a prototype or a friend of mine
wrote job scripts for me one time in a
toxis I get paid to write spaghetti code
for a living so it's awesome
I mean you xampp' wrote ever it
literally is like it's got a run for 12
people who are usability study and it
never sees the light of day so but I
know in the real world testing is
important they actually I'm tool called
spectrum which you can use to leverage
and actually run proper unit tests with
mocha and chai or whatever and actually
begin to test your application which is
probably rather important especially if
you start thinking about fact this is
desktop application a lot more security
starts to come into play because you
have access to everything in here you
know you can say I'm going to erase your
hard drive you know you a lot of power a
lot of responsibility comes in writing
an electron app and you want to make
sure it's it's working well um real
simple installation boom so let's talk
about building your application we'll
get to some demos at the end
so you need to somehow sort of compile
all these bits into something
distributable something that may go into
the Mac App Store the Windows Store on a
server that looks and smells like a real
application the preferred tool is this
module called electron builder and
really it only takes a little bit of
change to your setup so like it was
mentioning earlier that's what you kind
of throw some stuff in the app folder
like that it's gonna start writing stuff
out to the build and distribution folder
it's a very well maintained project as
always that question you should ask
yourself with any sort of open source
tool how well machined is it you know am
I going to be hitting life you know two
months from now when a critical bug hits
and I'm completely in trouble so it's
just nice to have a good maintained
library it will build for all our
platforms it will build for our various
architectures so if you have to deal for
you know packed into 32 bit or 64 back
windows it will do all that for you
basically in that package JSON file we
need to update our scripts to basically
tell it to run build what we want to
build for and then we need to define a
whole bunch of properties these are
actually very real document we have to
give an app ID everyone needs an app ID
that's how the world you know thesis so
straight copyrights you know the name
it's going to be what elect version of
electron I want a package in there
category from putting us in the App
Store for Mac where it's gonna live
what kind of installer for Windows what
I want to do for Linux how anyone should
with their app icons etc etc all start
you I put them all in here those are the
things you started defining here if you
feel like said you ever worked with
Cordova this is sort of the equivalent
of the config dot XML file just they you
have to use JSON because ten years ago
so really you know what you just
basically have to point to where that
new starter
is it's all good to go make your app
Thai icons in there you have to go a
little further
like for the Mac you know you've
probably have opened DM G's disk images
and you've probably seen something you
know really nice like this you know okay
take this icon this app put it over here
in this you know alias Applications
folder message sent to the Installer but
you have to tell it where this graphic
is now big it is and what those things
are and it will create that dmg for you
make the zip and there they're your bits
same thing with Windows it will make
your windows installers I know if
anyone's ever tried to make the windows
installer but oh there's so much fun so
really just take a lot of the pain out
of it there are a couple variations on
the two types of windows installers out
there yes or not but you get to define
this is the real simple one you can have
a more formal one and you can start to
define sidebar graphics and header
graphics and make make it look you know
like a real software developer knew what
they were doing when they made this
installer it's really nice auto updating
this was a hard part this was actually
more interesting than I thought I almost
kind of feel like they got to the forum
like oh we just got to add it and move
on it is built into electron however the
amount of additional work with the
default electron auto update system
really left my head scratching because
they're not even on top of the same
worlds so for Mac OS is going to use the
system called squirrel dot Mac which is
different than the squirrel for Windows
and will Linux actually sorry out a lot
completely but for the Mac one to work
you're going to have your own server up
and running sending back a JSON file
when requested to then send the update
around and all this like I said I'm a
prototype I'm a front-end guy I'm like
what server what 200 response was what
package Oh
No please help me help me
so instead there's a lovely alternative
package out there called electron
updater and there's actually a sort of I
call a third party group solectron
usually and I believe they actually have
written quite a few so that electron
builder tool I mentioned earlier it's
the same group also has done this I also
got an electron forgers talk about a
second this is an alternative to the
electrons built-in updater and the nice
thing is it doesn't worry about the
whole server response sort of stuff so
you just basically drop this in as a
replacement and life is good again so
you pull in their auto update or not
electrons and then you can basically
listen on to various events it goes out
to a URL it asks some stuff and then
check if there's an update not update
download an error so you can have it do
a silent install a prompt install so all
that updating you've seen inside of
really BS code stuff like that it's all
living on this much much simpler than
like standing up your own Heroku
instance and uploading stuff and hoping
you did it right that's sort of thing so
but yeah it is electron use oh and
they've also started another project
which I was just playing with toward the
end of the book this thing called
electron Forge which is really an
electron CLI it's almost the whole
collection of tools to make all this
even simpler it was just getting off the
ground so I'm like oh we don't want to
rewrite the book and we're already late
so just mention noting it so that's the
book that's me let me show you some
demos
all right so make a little bigger so
before actually rubbing this thing so
here's the package.json file you can see
we're a little test and got distribution
in there if your keywords and we're def
dependencies build script type stuff let
me just go ahead and run this oh it's
right
that's right I moved it that's what I
get for cleaning up before I start
yeah
right yes oh yeah I read you may have
noticed that presentation I just gave
you was electron app actually that was
just revealed Jay s that I really just
dropped in to the quick start replacing
existing files and was just an electro
not so it literally is that easy to take
a web app and slap it into electron app
now I didn't do anything to desica file
that's a no word things like you know
what were the keyboard you know putting
up a proper menu keyboards we do this
eccentric okay no no that was done but
it's a little as simple as it was
so here's electrum so those little
chrome tools I was talking about right
there I forgot to pull them there if you
see render but that's okay you know I
can pull up my my dialog box and then
you know I can see what we have down
here I can choose a directory all these
things that I want to assembly processes
there's you know console.log back and
forth and this is all that code I was
talking about through the presentation
so pull the P modules I basically go
flying the document again keeping it
vanilla and you know contextual menus so
if I come back over and ctrl-click you
know I get a real contextual menu inside
my HTML and do something with it but
custom menu there's my custom menu out
so oh and there's a reason why the
buttons are purple look up Rebecca
purple but here are the things back and
forth just what I was showing you think
I'll just simply put up inside the thing
inside there over in the main j/s here's
where I'm creating the window
a little bit of the menus
you said the menus can get a little
larger this is where some of that file
management loading in would be probably
advantageous generate the icon custom
functions and that sort of thing so that
is you know kind of the start of
electron and here let me show you what's
possible it's right there so here's ion
generator so we have that splash screen
and then here we have this application
right here this is an electron
application and now in the app store
it's signing go that far the UI actually
is the ionic framework so even I'm
taking a mobile framework and actually
pulled into the desktop so I have the
ability to go through here and the idea
is if you've worked with ionic it comes
with a CLI I can never remember all the
parameters and it actually doesn't do
everything that you would need to set up
your ionic application things like
adjusting the manifest.json file for
progressive web app updating the XML
file you were deploying it to a native
mobile app pulling in the various
plugins the Cordova plugins this
actually was I said well let's just play
around with it so I can go through it
start to define my manifest.json over
here come over to Cordova yeah I know
there's no platform start to pulling
things a lot of flying splash means
things that would do in a Cordova
application yes I know it employed I can
start having me scrolling lists pulling
in plugins I can pull in lock testing
and eventually have it execute the CLI
in the terminal all my user system so I
don't even paste out like now don't copy
this into a terminal it would actually
run and build meiotic application all
through a GUI so if you have a bunch of
command line tools lying around you
could actually write a UI making a lot
more friendly with more safeguards and
actually just use electron to actually
run those headless things for you and go
from there but that is a brief look at
just you know just the top veneer of
what electron is sort of sampling what
the tools it can give you the hard part
is you know writing all the application
logic you know doesn't solve that for
you but it really gives you a nice other
solution to take that web app take that
idea out of the browser you know where
you've probably had to say to your boss
oh the browser won't let me do that
oh yeah desktop can well now you can
so with that that is electron